what's up Theo what's up TJ hey I'm from
Arkansas had a quick question for you TJ
do you have it in every one of your
contracts that no matter what you can do
whatever the [ __ ] you want with your
facial hair kind of looks like you just
wing it every time and I think it's
awesome Gang Gang Gang our kids he's got
he's obviously on break he's got the
safety vest on safety first baby you
know I think that's that's a good point
and also from a gentleman with great
facial hair look at how he's right in
the middle
he's got nothing going on he's doing
when I'm doing which was taking off the
soul patch but he's got a good sort of
length of beard good on you man it's
everybody's like contract but I think
it's understood just like that I'm gonna
improvise so you can't expect me to just
do the lines as written even sometimes
I'll say I don't think this is the right
lines
yeah I'll notice that even when I walk
on there I'm like he had there has to be
yeah and I'll also provide I'm not gonna
come and say I don't like that line what
else do you got because I'm a writer
I'll come and I'll say okay I don't
think that's really the funniest line or
doesn't quite fit here so here's about
five other options that I came up with
and let's talk like what do you think
would be good so just like people expect
that they kind of know that I'm going to
do with my appearance what I want the
drew Barrymore film which is called the
stand and in the stand-in I did I
I cut weight and had the same facial
hair and haircut as my former manager
mm-hmm Barry Katz that's the no that's
the that's the character that I'm sort
of playing is that as that manager I
split amicably with hmm and and so they
just knew I talked to the director about
it but they just know I'm gonna have a
very specific idea the weirdest thing
that ever happened to me with regards to
can I do whatever the [ __ ] I want is I
did this movie called ready player one I
should say this picture called ready
player one and I was really nervous the
night before I just was like I'm not
really an actor I'm a comedian should I
be reading an acting book or something
I'm about to go in and Steven Spielberg
is gonna direct
me and is that shahi should I be more
prepared and I was just pacing outside
of the weirdest state that they put us
up and around this fountain just pacing
pacing pacing and finally I was kind of
like you know what you've never worried
about this with any other film like just
change your voice that's what you do for
everything that's what you did for
Wiesel and Deadpool that's what you do
now he surtax like this and then Erlich
from Silicon Valley sort of talks more
like this and I was like okay let's
figure out what that what is the and I
thought about it's like he's a bounty
hunter in this video game world he's
obviously a nerd because he plays video
games non-stop all the time it's how he
makes his money everything I said well
who would be his idol Boba Fett right I
mean obviously that's who we all love
from Star Wars and this guy's actually a
bounty hunter so I just studied Boba
Fett's he only has like five lines oh
wow cops that cop some of that vibe yeah
cop that vibe and then went in and I was
like all right I'm just gonna ask
Stephen Spielberg you know does he think
this is a good idea and if it's not then
I'm just gonna say to him I you know I'm
open to anything else and just let him
kind of direct yes he handsome guy
handsome guy
the Avadh first person for that to be
she looks like but also yeah let's pull
him up but I think yeah he's a handsome
guy he's definitely got an iconic look
he kind of he's got a little bit of a
look like you look there he is yeah yeah
some guy but like he's got his own look
oh yeah I could see me look like David
Spade's dad like - its dad we're getting
some serious nodding in the booth with
that observation right on it does not
not very buddy he's the nicest guy you
think how intimidating so I go up to him
oh yeah be intimidated and I say so I
was thinking you know his idol this I
rock this I rocks idol would be Boba
Fett you know because that's this so I
thought I would change my voice and kind
of talk like Boba Fett what do you think
about that and he goes yeah I think
that's great let's yeah let's do that
whatever you think and it was so insane
this guy kind of go well it's obviously
whatever you want it to be yeah because
to him he hired you I heard Woody Allen
is like this he hired you and hiring you
was the last he wants to do with you
you're supposed to figure out what
you're gonna do and he trusts that
you're that's the reason he hired you
was and even in that one I said thank
you Steven Spielberg for having me in
your movie he said oh yeah no there's no
one else we wrote the part for you and I
thought oh my god that's crazy but it's
that he thought about the movie he's a
fan of mine it's been helping me
throughout my career and was like TJ
I'll do great with this so whatever he
wants to do he'll do with it and it
worked out really well and he'll give
you you know he'll give you notes and
stuff obviously but it's really notes on
how to improve your performance but as
far as the facial hair and that one I
did they did give a [ __ ] because I had
to shave because I was in the game and
so I had to have a hundred and fifty
black dots all over my face and wear one
of those skin tight suits with the
ping-pong balls all over it and a helmet
with two little cameras and lights that
so I was all motion capture Wow the most
parts it was really that was a crazy
experience but I guess the real answer
that question is yes I or no I do not in
my contract say I can do whatever the
[ __ ] I want with my face shark sometimes
Steven Spielberg wants to be a clean
baby boys but yeah on your face you got
a show-up diaper ready
you know what's crazy as my sister can't
even read but what does it have to do
with us right now hope you enjoyed that
video and you can watch another and you
can watch this one you can watch this
one different options different choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy two options watch one this one
guess what